les gens respirent de l'air dans lequel
il ya du glyphosate des pesticides de
synthèse
ils sont une quarantaine de maires en
france qui comme daniel cueff ont décidé
d'interdire totalement le glyphosate sur
leur territoire sa petite commune située
en bretagne compte 600 habitants et 7
cents vaches ses concitoyens lui
demander d'agir depuis longtemps 35
habitants ont fait des prélèvements
d'uriné
beaucoup d'entre eux mangent 100% bio
leurs enfants mangent bio à la cantine
municipale et ils ont découvert des taux
de glyphosate 30 fois supérieur à la
norme autorisée
ils sont tombés de leur armoire à raison
ils ont dit mais c'est impossible on
pensait avoir un peu de diffuseurs mais
à ce point c'est pas possible
mais le maire de langouët ces habitats
ont été déçus la cour a cassé la
décision le temps de juger sur le fond à
savoir si oui ou non le glyphosate est
bel et bien dangereux pour la santé car
les agences de sécurité sanitaire en
europe comme aux états unis ou au canada
qui sont censés veiller sur l'impact de
l'environnement sur notre santé ne
considère pas le glyphosate comme
cancérogènes malgré l'avis contraire de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
ce sont des agences qui s'appuie
essentiellement sur les documents
secrets de l'industrie et non pas sur
les publications scientifiques qui ont
été faites au cours des dernières années
la sociologue de l'uqam louise vandelac
spécialisé en environnement a été outrée
de voir que santé canada a autorisé le
glyphosate jusqu'en 2032 n'y voyant
aucun problème pour la santé des
canadiens
quand il s'agite études qui sont faites
par les scientifiques
ce sont des études qui dort plus des
deux tiers des cas sont des études
critiques qui mettent en évidence
certains risques pour la santé
ce qui est le cas de moins de 1% des
études faites par l'industrie
en effet selon les compilations récente
les études faites par les scientifiques
indépendants conclu dans 70% des cas que
le glyphosate est bel et bien toxiques
celles financées par monsanto
aujourd'hui propriété de la firme
allemande beyer le producteur de rôle
d'appât dix
le contraire dans 99% des cas qui dit
vrai darwind pro la controverse est
transporté devant les tribunaux qui de
plus en plus auront à trancher en 2018
cet employé municipal d'une banlieue de
san francisco atteint d'un cancer les
plus souvent lié au glyphosate a fait
l'histoire
il a réussi à démontrer que sa maladie
était causée par l'épandage du roundup
qui faisait partie de son travail
le tribunal a condamné monsanto à lui
verser près de 300 millions de dollars
cette décision contestée en appel par la
compagnie a été la première quelques
autres ont suivi qui vont dans le même
sens et ce n'est pas fini
à ce jour 18 mille quatre cents
personnes ont entrepris des actions en
justice contre monsanto beyers aux états
unis 175 au canada et 55 au québec ici
alexandre achat de ce cas radio canada
montréal